não dá o toque
olá pessoal daqui que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos de mais um v e em
mostrar de que em mim e quero julgado
este jogo de estratégia é que neca preta
para ela sumir tem de olhar para ela ter
seu parceiro e elo é o palhaço não
continue cheio pois tem um pé na perna
eu tenho um boneca preta que tem que
olhar pra ela tem o palhaço que nunca
não posso mexer e tem três vícios não
por ser mais à frente com um tentar
primeiro culpa deus mesmo
estamos de volta à nossa casa em mim ea
onyx momento tem que ficar o erro né
agora é só ficar assim o funcionou a
cair agora por onde é que eu tenho que
não faço a mínima ideia kloch por o
odonto do que terry pois agora já
percebi painel cristo não sei que bateu
na porta aqui no porto nem sequer é um
eixo direito do monitor do santa rosa
aqui vou olhar para ela ficou para ela
aí só isso tem que fazer então mil
finalmente já sei jogar este jogo ou
música esta ou néné eu acho que já tive
aqui é que não é aquela capa no
semanário baixo ontem que uma porta
escondida e xixi aqui não funciona ou
cai vamos lá então tentar outra coisa
vamos lá está a explorar o outro lado da
casa esta porta aqui o que estou aqui
para lutar quando ela fica o hotel ou 90
por seu eu vou tentar entrar aqui nesta
escuridão e ver o que acontece falou
nenhuma luz daquilo que é o disco não
tinha tudo legista um não da roupa eu
vou tentar entrar aqui dentro eu acho
que estou com um cara que parar né
aproveito e faço aqui uma ginástica ó ó
sinto poder destinar
sim eu sou deficiente pode ser por seu
caísse no uai
a hilco é hoje que vai rachado eu sou
hoje
além do toque fosse código morse
ok membros da porta aí eu voltei à sala
ela vai pagando joãozinho é gente
aprende como por exemplo é maninho nessa
maleta triunfo rica no chão nosso
partido uma porta vamos direto pra porta
vamos já direto na memória guiné foi
outro que ela corta oi conta não só as
cordas ato silencioso tá tudo muito
silencioso no meu filhinho de uma
cultura aqui né não o segundo campeão eu
sou muito pregão ela não desaparece
porque agora perder tempo a dar o passe
para seu eu posso usar isso pode
destruir ele né
vamos tentar entrar aqui agora à caraças
não pelos cunha um pouco meu o nosso
mesmo por céu e é editor tido já a
semana e o palhaço vai por si quando não
sai do confuso steel está este está
muito confuso do que eu estava olhando
pra ela meu não
eu finjo que vocês disseram não está
rolando
não não estamos através da casa nem mil
e 10 mil no muito podre simão jatene
chegando logo não sair
eu sei que ele um buraco qualquer menino
e que havia qualquer coisa que vocês
tenham gostado eu ainda não percebi o
que tem que fazer mesmo de outros
ninguém por favor
eis o acordo com o site favorito fiquei
mata próxima